hey luke congratulations
thank you
um i'm wondering i remember you telling
a story that i still think is very funny
to this day about being invited on tour
with chris young and they saved you a
bus slot and you pulled in with your
little dodge neon i did
and i'm wondering when you think back to
that guy
who is just hoping to maybe get to play
some songs for a living to now being the
cma entertainer of the year yeah look
through your mind
i don't know i i mean i hadn't processed
it at all to be completely honest with
you um
i mean this is
you know there's so many people that
make this happen i mean my whole team
me my abandon crew my road crew i mean
my you know management label booking i
mean there has to be hundreds of people
that made this happen
so i'm not sure how to feel yet to be
honest with you obviously i'm incredibly
excited
overjoyed like lifetime dream come true
achieved and
i'm just trying to
just trying to figure out what to feel
to be honest with you it just doesn't
seem real to be to be completely honest
with you hi lou congratulations hello
thank you so i want to talk about your
song that you performed doing this the
unreleased track um thank you for
sharing that with us today can you talk
a little bit about that song i know it's
a really personal one to you yeah
definitely me and you know um the guys i
was nominated
for song of the year with tonight wrote
that song uh as well with me and um
we were sitting in the in the man cave
at my house probably
three quarters of the way through 2020
and
we we couldn't come up with anything to
write about to be honest with you didn't
have a title or an idea and they're just
sitting on the back porch talking and i
said you know i get asked in interviews
a lot you know what would you be doing
if you weren't doing this and
the answer was always you know jokingly
i would say well i would be homeless it
would be my joking answer but
it's like i really don't there was never
a plan b like once i decided
that this is what i was going to do it's
what i was going to do whether that was
at this level or at the level that i was
at when i started i would be chasing
this if i wasn't holding it in my hand
right now and i'll always be doing that
you know i mean
music is the thing that i think makes
everybody who does what i do is you know
blood pump and gets them out of bed in
the morning and just to be able to do
that write a song about it that you feel
like genuinely can connect with some of
your peers
is really cool so i was i was honored to
be able to play a new one tonight and i
hope everybody loved it
awesome thank you awesome thank you hey
you and i have talked quite a few times
about how you've always impressed me by
using your platform to help other people
and now that this
now that the mantle falls on your
shoulder i wonder what your thoughts are
about
continuing that goal which has always
been a mission for you and also leading
country music forward because like i
said it's kind of
at least for the next year and probably
farther than that like you're the leader
yeah that's that's uh pretty crazy to
think about man um you know i'll just
i mean when i started out
you know i was
the same guy that my parents raised and
i feel like i was
you know before i won this trophy and i
feel like i am now so i think continuing
to be that person um continuing to be
humble
obviously you know being excited i'm
excited that i won man everybody that
that's nominated for this award wants to
win and you just feel like it's a big i
don't care what i don't care what is
going on
ah look at that baby
holy cow excuse me
but man it's um
you just wanna you just want to uh you
know i've always just wanted to be a guy
that people felt like they wanted to
root for um felt like a guy that could
be their neighbor a guy they wanted to
have a beer with and um i feel like i'll
always be that guy man it's just who i
am it's never going to change and uh
very thankful